mmm-hmm nothing to give my broker
[Music]
you know I can't help but smile when I
see you seriously you're just always so
ready to [ __ ] with the highwayman it's
cool it's really cool I like that well
my friend there is more work to do in
that department
reminds me of lag on when I was a kid
find the supplies in our radio you the
extraction point
and don't forget to gear up good luck be
careful the package as a GPS tracker
where it goes
the hi women follow bonne chance
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
watch you can take our dear
[Music]
get away go for the chopper
heads up I'm coming in time to get the
[ __ ] out of here ID
you yeah I'm here for you I know what's
this anyone here follow me
why the craving that teeth breaking
crush gotta go right for the face every
time they never see it coming
had that rose to dog before coming scabs
all waiting hey you need a fighting name
before you go in there so we know who to
bet again clearly alone it's all over
face all right squirt lollipop it is get
into the ring lollipop
[Music]